cuándo
[Música]
crecen las preocupaciones ante la vacuna
kobe 19 de oxford astrazéneca a varios
países europeos suspendieron su
aplicación e investiga en casos de
coágulos en la sangre lado ms llamó a no
ceder ante el pánico en paralelo a una
reunión de la autoridad europea de
medicamentos que revisa si la fórmula es
segura
desde corea del norte de kim jong
hermana del líder del país kim jong-un
amenazó con romper el pacto de 2018 que
rebaja la atención militar con corea del
sur esa es la respuesta a las maniobras
militares conjuntas de seúl y washington
y el primer contacto con el nuevo
gobierno de eeuu comandado por joe biden
y durante esta semana france24 cuenta
las historias de los jóvenes sirios en
el exilio ahora que se cumplen 10 años
de uno de los peores conflictos bélicos
del mundo moderno la de hoy es la
vivencia de sawyer un joven de 24 años
que encontró una segunda oportunidad en
francia tras pasar un año como refugiado
en turquía
regresamos con ustedes para actualizar
la información más importante de américa
latina y del mundo crecen las
preocupaciones por los posibles efectos
negativos de la vacuna kobe y 19
desarrollada por oxford astrazéneca
varios países suspendieron su aplicación
mientras se investigan casos de coágulos
en la sangre y un fallecimiento la
organización mundial de la salud llamó a
no ceder ante el pánico y continuar con
las campañas en paralelo a una reunión
de la autoridad europea de medicamentos
o de que revisa la inyección para el
análisis se nos acompaña el señor de
daniel lópez acuña médico epidemiólogo
ex director del departamento de acción
sanitaria en situación de crisis de la
organización mundial de la salud gracias
por acompañarnos y un panel de expertos
de la oms está reunido hoy en ginebra
para examinar los datos sobre el uso de
la vacuna de astrazéneca lo mismo hace
la ema existe una causalidad entre la
vacuna y los efectos de trombosis
en estos momentos no se puede establecer
una relación causal se está examinando
la evidencia tanto el panel en ginebra-
de lado ms como el de la agencia europea
del medicamento resolverán si hay en
efecto una relación causal y eso ya nos
llevará a una decisión definitiva más
allá de las decisiones cautelares
prudenciales que se han tomado hemos
visto varios países europeos que
anunciaron que dejan de vacunar con
astrazéneca pero a diferencia en reino
unido país al que pertenece la empresa
junto con suecia siguen utilizándola y
no reportan ninguna afectación como
explicar esto podrían moverse algunos
intereses en esta decisión
siempre existe la posibilidad de que hay
un interés de guerra comercial o un
interés geopolítico pero yo creo que lo
que tenemos que hacer es ajustarnos a la
evidencia científica de si hay o no
efectos secundarios que puedan ser
atribuibles a la vacuna hasta el momento
se trata de un efecto muy infrecuente en
el caso de españa- por ejemplo donde
vivo yo ha sido un caso de trombosis en
800 mil vacunas estamos hablando de una
frecuencia de un evento que puede
también darse no asociado a la vacuna y
que puede estar ligado a alguna
condición preexistente o al uso de algún
medicamento previo o algunas
características de susceptibilidad
individual pero no debemos interpretarlo
como que la vacuna es insegura ni
debemos de tener una noción de que hay
que llamarse a extrañeza o sea o
establecer una alarma ante la vacuna de
hasta cerca bueno y es que estamos en
emergencia mundial
nos urge la vacunación así que le
pregunto qué efectos puede tener en la
toma de estas medidas drásticas de parar
las inoculaciones con astrazéneca en los
procesos de campañas de inmunización
bueno para los países europeos que han
detenido la vacunación evidentemente
esto va a significar reducir la
velocidad a la que van avanzando en sus
programas de vacunación en estos
momentos los países se están vacunando
en europa con tres vacunas facer
modernas y astrazéneca se acaba de
aprobar la de johnson y johnson y
entrará en vigor muy pronto mientras más
dispongamos de distintas vacunas
eficaces y seguras más rápido podremos
avanzar en la vacunación pero por
supuesto detenerse 15 días aunque sea
cautelarmente por un principio de
prudencia bueno disminuye la intensidad
a la que se produce esta vacuna estos
son países que estaban vacunando con
astrazéneca a personas menores de 55
años ahí es en donde se ha detenido pero
yo considero que tendremos una evidencia
muy clara en breve que permitirá
reanudar la vacunación si no hay ninguna
prueba de que hay algún efecto causal de
la vacuna con la trombosis pues
esperaremos los resultados de las
investigaciones gracias a ustedes
doctores y continuamos con más noticias
la hermana del líder de corea del norte
kim jong
con los ejercicios militares de corea
del sur que realiza en conjunto con eeuu
y advirtió que el olor a pólvora en la
frontera intercoreana no ayudará a traer
la paz es el primer mensaje público a
washington es desde que asumió joe biden
en una relación que empieza con
agresividad más temprano a nuestro
corresponsal en seúl a andrés sánchez
nos habló sobre la seriedad de estas
amenazas
pues desde luego que son amenazas serias
tengamos en cuenta que kim jong y
amenazó el pasado verano con destruir la
oficina de enlace intercoreano y lo hizo
al final así que si amenaza con
desintegrar este órgano que menciona
perfectamente puede hacerlo kim jong es
una persona con mucho peso en todo el
régimen es subdirectora de un importante
órgano de propaganda y desde el año
pasado es además una de las principales
portavoces además asumiendo digamos un
papel casi como de policía malo es la
persona encargada de comunicar los
mensajes más duros del régimen hoy ha
criticado estas maniobras militares que
mencionabas pero que a su vez han sido
reducidas en escala mucho debido a la
pandemia de este modo casi lo más
importante el mensaje más allá de las
maniobras es el mensaje que trata enviar
a seúl ya washington en vísperas del
viaje a la región del secretario estado
y de defensa estadounidenses anthony
blinken y lloyd austin que llegan mañana
miércoles a seúl y es que este viaje es
muy importante para ultimar y coordinar
la que va a ser la nueva estrategia de
washington y sus aliados regional
con corea del norte corea del norte no
quiere un enfoque paciente quiere
retornar cuanto antes a la mesa de
negociación porque su economía se
encuentra en una mala situación por la
pandemia y como ya anunció a kim jong-un
en enero y hoy ha vuelto a insinuar su
hermana si no se produce pronto ese
retorno a la mesa de negociación corea
del norte va a volver a probar pronto
armas nucleares y misiles en su viaje a
japón el secretario de estado de eeuu y
el jefe de la cartera de defensa se
reunieron con sus homólogos nipones y
emitieron una acusación conjunta contra
china señalaron a beijing de ser
incoherente con el orden internacional
principalmente por las actividades
militares del país en la región del
pacífico y por la situación de la
minoría uigur anthony blinken y lloyd
austin y sus homólogos nipones
toshimitsu motegi y no jugó quiz y
aseguraron que si china usa la fuerza
para imponer su voluntad responderán en
la misma medida
por cuarta vez desde el inicio de la
pandemia el presidente de brasilia air
bolsonaro nombró un nuevo ministro de
salud el designado es el cardiólogo
marcelo quiroga a quien el mandatario
elogió esta decisión es sobre la que ya
se especulaba llega sin explicación
clara y en medio de alarmantes cifras de
fallecidos por kobe 19 con un balance
que se acerca a los 280 mil muertos
informa juan pupiales oncólogo un
diputado y un general del ejército son
los ministros que han abandonado la
cartera de salud en brasil desde el
comienzo de la pandemia ahora el
designado es el presidente de la
sociedad brasileña de cardiología
marcelo quiroga quien estará al frente
de un área clave en medio de una
situación crítica por la pandemia de
sida gustos ya lo conocía de hace
algunos años entonces no es alguien a
quien acabe de conocer en mi opinión
tiene todo para hacer un buen trabajo
continuando con lo que pasó él lo ha
hecho hasta hoy
el general eduardo para suelo era hasta
la tarde del lunes el ministro de salud
e incluso anunció
el pedido de 138 millones de doce de
facer y johnson and johnson el propio
para suelo reconoció que su salida era
posible aunque desde el gobierno no ha
habido ninguna explicación clara
puede ser a corto mediano o largo plazo
el presidente está en este intento de
reorganizar el ministerio
solo la semana pasada el gigante
sudamericano acumuló una cifra de
fallecidos por encima de la de cualquier
otro país en el mundo con balances
diarios que superaron los 2 mil decesos
al día pero desde el gobierno han
existido de mantener en marcha la
economía promoviendo tratamientos con
hidroxi cloroquina cuestionada por la
comunidad científica a nivel regional
ejecutivos como el del estado de sao
paulo el más grande de brasil con 46
millones de habitantes hacen caso omiso
a la línea del gobierno el gobernador
optó por permitir desde este lunes el
funcionamiento solo de los negocios
esenciales además de un toque de queda
entre las 8 de la noche y las 5 de la
mañana hasta el 30 de marzo
y en bolivia miles de personas salieron
a las calles el lunes en una muestra de
apoyo a jeanine áñez la ex presidenta
interina pasó su primera noche en una
cárcel de la paz donde deberá cumplir
cuatro meses de prisión preventiva
mientras es investigada por su edición
de terrorismo y conspiración por la
salida del poder del ex presidente evo
morales en 2019 lo que él más ha
denunciado como un golpe de estado'
matías a raíz de los detalles los tiene
la detención de la ex líder interina
jeanine áñez ha desatado fuertes
protestas en toda bolivia
concentraciones en las principales
ciudades del país condenando un juicio
político hemos comprobado que este
gobierno al estilo venezolano no quiere
por ningún medio que se respete la
voluntad popular
que es que no queremos más con una
dictadura fascista en el poder la
oposición de derecha y de centro niega
que haya existido un golpe de estado en
noviembre de 2019 como afirma el
gobierno socialista que regresó al poder
en octubre pasado al acusar al gobierno
de agnès de derrocar a evo morales
contenta
[Aplausos]
en cochabamba la ciudad del líder
izquierdista evo morales
una multitud también salió a las calles
a pedir la liberación de áñez
[Aplausos]
la detención de yanina 10 que dice ser
víctima de una persecución política ha
provocado desde el sábado numerosas
reacciones en bolivia y en el extranjero
la portavoz adjunta del departamento de
estado en washington pidió que se
respete el debido proceso la oea instó a
la liberación de los detenidos en el
poder de noviembre de 2019 a noviembre
de 2020 la expresidenta áñez fue puesta
en detención preventiva durante cuatro
meses en una cárcel de mujeres en la paz
ahora que se cumplen diez años del
inicio de las revueltas en siria que
llevaron a una sangrienta guerra civil
les traemos perfiles de jóvenes sirios
refugiados en el exterior en el episodio
de hoy conoceremos a ságer de 24 años
luego de pasar un año en los campos de
refugiados de turquía este reportero
gráfico halló una nueva oportunidad en
parís en 2018 allí pudo retomar su vida
y continuar su trabajo como periodista
ya mira voy a mostrarte algo ya eres
casi un estudiante como cualquier otro
hoy me dieron mi pluma del 10
es un diploma de estudios en lengua
francesa su primer diploma francés
espera seguir mejorando mi nivel de
lengua francesa con jose
a este joven sirio lo entrevistamos a su
llegada a francia tres años atrás en ese
entonces no hablaba una sola palabra de
francés y contaba en un inglés precario
el horror de la guerra
[Música]
esa día las fuerzas del régimen atacaron
a los civiles
mataron 32 personas sólo sobrevivió este
bebé
hoy compartir su historia con los
jóvenes de todo el país
ella desde sucesión y me contacte de
asociaciones universidades y liceos me
contactaron para que le asisten a
conferencias
para compartir mi experiencia y trabajo
con los estudiantes
y para responder a algunos estudiantes
me han dicho es interesante te cuenta
porque es algo que nos da la información
la tele
saber sólo tenía 15 años cuando estalló
la batalla de alguien su casa fue
destruida por los bombardeos informaba
sobre los combates desde las posiciones
rebeldes a su llegada a francia le
sorprendieron los hechos que eran
noticia decidió entonces relatar los
eventos de su nuevo mundo
cuando llegue a france 2018 hace las
manifestaciones de los chalecos
amarillos eran la noticia principal
luego en 2020 viene el confinamiento
entonces tomé fotos y yoga le duc porque
quería que los demás supieran que soy
periodista yo que sigo siendo reportero
gráfico y que quiero continuar mi
carrera aquí
una manera también de enviar noticias a
su familia que sigue en siria
hasta aquí el informativo ustedes
recuerde que puede seguirnos también en
france24 punto com para actualización de
estas y otras noticias por nuestro
equipo de redacción periodística siga
con nosotros en france 24 en minutos
regresamos con más información
[Música]